there are so many of you that graduate
this month and have no [__] idea what
you want to do and that's okay most
people don't you should not be stressed
about that I'm actually not scared about
that I'm scared that you don't realize
that you're entering the greatest
five-year window of your life if you are
22 years old graduating from college you
are entering first of all some of the
greatest years of your life but B this
is the moment watch this video twice if
Mama's watching this send this to your
daughter Sally right now because you
have to understand this next five-year
window is when you don't go practical
and safe this is not the time to get the
job Mom wanted you to this is not the
time to try to maximize as much money so
you can buy a fat whip this is the time
to realize that you have a five-year
window and it's three for some it's
eight for others but this is a five-year
window for you to attack the life that
you want to win